this is a production of Cornell
University
what I like to do with my time here
today is to talk about a survey that I
and others have been very involved with
over the last year and to give you the
survey results and both are some very to
some very specific questions and most of
the information will be presented in
charts on the very specific questions
and then we had some open-ended
questions that also created and
generated some very good information
about what growers are thinking and then
before I finish up Andy mentioned
immigration reform I want to put some of
the things that we found in this survey
in the context of immigration reform
because that is so much on the mind of
growers today and has so much relevance
to the future of labor intensive
agriculture like like apple growing let
me start by recognizing the co-authors
of this study first of all is Paul Baker
Paul is the executive director of the
New York State horticultural society
Paul said that if Paul actually came to
me and and asked if we could do this
survey and he said that he would help
get the survey out and get the responses
back which he did Alison de mariée
retired over the last year as the
regional fruit specialist but her
background in fruit production and
economics was very invaluable to this
project Nicole ho was a grad student
from the Dyson school who helped do data
analysis I took the leadership on
writing the report which will be out
shortly and Brad rickard helped with
with the data analysis and the
manuscript review and input on the
report so let me tell you about what we
did and let me first say that Paul Baker
in the horde society spends a lot of his
time working with the Labor Department
and other government agencies getting
them to understand a horticulture and in
this case the Apple industry and one of
the things that one of his motivations
was that if he has specific information
about what goes on in the orchard he can
help inform the process of regulating
through Labor Department and other
agencies the other motivation the
motivation for us an extension is to
have a data set and be able to say
something more about the industry and
about workforce issues in the Apple
industry then what our government data
sets give us today yes we get labor
information from the Census and we get
some from the New York New York egg
statistics and there is something called
the net the agricultural worker survey
out of out of Washington but none of
those give us the detail that we can get
when we do a survey such as this so we
Paul through the hort society took the
initiative to may allow 480 surveys to
apple growers who contribute to the New
York State Apple order for promotion we
asked it was a three page survey we
asked the growers to report their
information based on the 2013 growing
season we got 95 usable responses back
about twenty percent response rate we
were
early pleased with that and one of the
things that I want to point out right up
front especially with so many grad
students in the audience is that this is
not a random sample this is 95 growers
who self selected to return our survey
form and as a result we have to be
careful about expanding to the entire
industry because I'll give you one
example here at the bottom of the slide
it just so so happens that the many of
the people who decided to send this back
happen to be growers who use the h-2a
program about half of them so this is
not a random sampling but nonetheless we
have more detailed information about
what's going on in New York apple farms
than is available elsewhere so the
number of bearing acres per farm this
slide gives you a sense that we did get
responses from every size group nineteen
percent were greater than 250 acres
nineteen percent were also less than 20
acres and then distributed in between
that as well but no one group was is far
larger than the other in terms of size
based on acres in the survey we asked
for their three-year average annual
apple production and specifically asked
for the three-year average because there
was a very poor year with frost damage
and cold damage to the crop that really
reduced some people's yield a couple of
years ago so that's why we asked for the
three-year average and you can see how
that distributes as well
and then we asked for the total number
of workers and not surprisingly the
workers we you can see very visually
there that the workers are concentrated
in the top two size groups 100 to 250
acres and over 250 acres and then we did
we asked each grower what region that
they produced in and so there are far
more charts that will be in the report
then I'm able to provide here today but
we were able to to crosstab between
regions and get some interesting
information and so there are basically
four apple growing regions in the state
central and western New York northern
New York eastern New York and Long
Island Long Island is not a very big
player in all this although Long Island
is a very horticultural spot for New
York State there aren't all that many
apples grown in Long Island but this
gives you a sense of how many how much
response we got from all over the state
we only got five responses from northern
New York but you can see that up and
that's the lake champlain region there
oh there are very few farms up there but
they account for a lot of the apple
production apple farms hiring h-2a
workers and so I alluded to this earlier
forty-eight percent said we hire on our
farm h-2a workers the other fifty two
percent said that they didn't now one of
the reasons why this is important is
there is that in that fifty two percent
very likely there are some growers who
have some undocumented work
who are working on their farm
anecdotally what what I find from
talking to growers is even if you are in
the h-2a program and hire some h-2a
workers you might also have some non
h-2a workers that are undocumented
workers and so it's many people have
looked at and discussed the fact that
even though we don't have specific
numbers undocumented workers are not
only a part of a labor-intensive agron
tensive agriculture but their part
likely of the New York Apple industry as
well for those of you who may not be
familiar with the h-2a program let me
just make a couple of comments about
that the h-2a program is a government
federal government run program operated
through the Labor Department that brings
in seasonal agricultural workers for
commercial farms in this country they
can come here for up to 10 months and
then they go home this time of year
growers are filling out their work
orders and planning ahead to get their
workers for the coming growing season
the home country of h-2a workers
primarily in this state most of the
workers are coming from Mexico and or
possibly other Central American
countries some are coming from there but
most of them are coming from Jamaica and
the I will just go into more detail in a
few minutes but the h-2a program is very
controversial it's expensive and there's
a lot of paperwork in red tape involved
in using the program so sometimes it's
criticized on the other hand if we look
at Lake to Lake Champlain area and other
areas of the state where Jamaican
workers come to work on apple farms and
we talked to the growers
we'll find that many times the growers
will say that these jamaican workers
have come here for sometimes for decades
for 20-30 years the same workers coming
back to work for eight to 10 weeks
they're very productive they're very
reliable from the growers perspective
and from the worker perspective they can
come for eight weeks or ten weeks and
make a fair amount of income compared to
their income potential at home and then
have a much better standard of living in
their home country length of seasonal
employment this just tells you that for
those growers that hire seasonal workers
twenty-eight percent just hire harvest
workers the other seventy two percent
hire workers throughout the season for
production various production practices
such as pruning and thinning and other
operations using a crew leader
twenty-six percent said that they did
use a hired crew leader and Alison de
Marie tells me that this number has
slowly decreased over the years and
continues to decrease worker experience
requirements now I want to go back to
Paul Baker and the horse society because
a few years ago with the h-2a program
one of the things that happened and
policies change and rules change based
on political administrations and for
some reason in the Labor Department the
Labor Department started to change their
philosophy of what experience was needed
for Apple pickers and and orchard
workers and consequently a farmer a few
farmers farmers would put in their work
order
and find out that and ask for a lot of
experience requirements and the Labor
Department said well you proud you don't
need all these work requirements and so
we're going to they ended up sending in
some cases less experienced workers and
this created some concern in the grower
community and so the growers went to
Paul Baker at the heart society and said
we need to document the kinds of
experience that workers need because
these are not unskilled jobs and so this
next set of slides gives you some idea
of the kinds of experience that growers
feel that they need when they're hiring
workers so thirty five percent said now
we can deal with the workforce away it
is we don't need a previous experience
but sixty-five percent said yes we
definitely need previous experience for
what we're trying to accomplish in our
orchard months of experience required by
types of work on the left hand side you
get a sense of the kinds of experience
that is needed pruning equipment
operation tractor driving picking for
both fresh and for process and then we
have this whole list of specific work
experience requirements some of which
growers not all growers asked for this
but some growers do ask for all of these
pruning chainsaw operation etc all these
different kinds of experience they want
the workers to have had for productivity
reasons before they show up on the job
then there's a picking requirement
people want workers that can pick
quickly and without bruising and so
there's not only so there's two
components to that requirement one is to
be very productive in
pick quickly and also not bruised the
fruit and so the average hours that we
found workers were working for picking
was 8.6 and they were doing all of these
they they might be asked to pick drop
apples they might be asked to do fresh
stem clipping spot picking cleaning the
whole tree and then picking for process
apples and the requirements on how fast
they do that depend upon how eat how
difficult or easy the job is to do now
many of you may be familiar with this
but but I learned a few things as an egg
economist doing this project and one of
the things I learned was about fresh
stem click clipping and if you don't
know what that is very often you have a
thin skinned Apple like Honey Crisp and
if you leave the stem on the apple and
that Apple gets in a bin with other
auntie crisp apples the stem is going to
pierce the skin of the other apples and
so so the worker the picker is given a
little set of clippers that look like
small scissors and that is used to do
the picking so now we've made this job
of picking apples even more complex
because they have to clip the stem when
they took the Apple instead of just
pulling it off the tree
how Apple pickers get paid soon we we
gave four choices for this by the hour
only twenty-six percent said that's how
they paid only by the piece fourteen
percent said that and then twenty-seven
percent said we have a combination of
peace rates and hourly rates depending
upon what we're doing and how easy or
difficult it is to do the job and that
also goes to the last one depends means
it depends upon how difficult it is to
do the job if a job gets difficult
enough and you can't make your peace
rate by doing that job it makes more
sense for a grower to use an hourly rate
and so we have all combinations of how
Pickers get paid wage rates so this will
give you an idea of wage rates for fresh
apples and this goes back to my comment
about the random sample if we had
average wage rates for the entire
industry they would be a bit lower than
what you see here but when you have
forty-eight percent of the growers in
this survey as h-2a growers the h-2a
rate is I'm not sure what it was for
2013 but it's around $11 it was around
eleven dollars per hour so these rates
are very likely higher than what would
be the average for the entire industry I
think wage rates are really important
that we keep an eye on them and take a
look at them examine them I'm going to
talk about immigration reform in a
minute one of the big challenges that we
have in agriculture is paying enough to
compete with other employers in the
geographic area that the business is in
and so
keeping an eye on and making sure our
wage rates are competitive is is an
important issue now and I think it's
going to become even more important in
the future and this just gives you an
idea of what the piece rates are piece
rates generally are by 20 bushel bin and
this gives you an indication of those as
well and as the rate as the job gets
more difficult we start with cleaning
the entire tree is the easiest job and
so that rates a little lower and that
goes all the way up to a much higher
rate for fresh stand clipping when that
is required in the orchard now one of
the things one of the opportunities we
have and this this is a good example of
the kinds of information that we cannot
get from other government data sets and
that is the week and asked in a survey
like this what are your worker shortage
issues do you have worker shortage
issues and I don't have I don't have my
slide I don't have the slide here for
the whole group but what that slide says
is that thirty-six percent of the
growers said in the in the whole of all
those who responded thirty-six percent
said that they were short of workers in
2013 and this gives you a bit of an idea
of a breakout by region of who said they
were sort of workers and who said that
they had sufficient workers and central
New York and northern New York indicated
that they were most short of workers
then we asked them along these same
lines what was the average number of
additional workers that you would have
hired if they were available for your
farm in 2013
and you can see that in in some of the
smaller farms that started out with two
workers and the very largest farm said
they would have hired almost 11 workers
full-time equivalent wise to work on the
farm if those workers were available
then we went one step further and said
well what do you as you look at your
workforce needs in the future what are
you anticipating and how many employees
do you think that you'll need three
years from now fewer less or stays the
same and seventy-four percent said that
they are we're anticipating with the
needs of their business that they were
going to need more employees than what
they hire today and this has real
implications for immigration reform and
how we wear these workers are going to
come from in the future and how we
source labor in the future and then
finally so the last thing that the
grower got in the cert when he was
filling out he or she was filling out
the survey was a couple of open-ended
questions and here's an opportunity for
us to ask some things about they can
answer the question any way they want
now it gets a little bit you have to
then do this grouping lumping process at
the end but we end up writing out all
the answers on summary sheets and it's
very interesting to look at what growers
say in an open-ended question when they
can answer it any way they like so we
asked them first what were the top three
issues that you think grower
organizations that work on your behalf
should work on in the next five years
labor availability and immigration and
h-2a and efficiency and all those things
were far and away above the
following2 so labor labor availability
was number one not surprising government
regulation is number two we hear that
all the time especially as the farm
grows in size and then marketing
consumer education global markets by
local all those marketing issues were
number three so this is what they said
they wanted organizations that they
belong to to do on their behalf in the
years ahead and this just is to
reinforce the point that we hear this
not only in the Apple industry today but
many many labor intensive industries
that labor workforce issues are our
number one management issue and if we
could solve that life would improve in
terms of managing the farm business now
to meet this what is the question that
was most interested me most of interest
to me when we put this together one of
the things that was on my mind a lot is
okay we all know that immigration reform
has stalled but the farm manager is
dynamic operates a dynamic business and
does not stop just because immigration
reform is stalled they have to keep
running this business because they have
such a large capital investment in many
cases so we asked the survey
participants given the labor pressures
that you've experienced in the last
several years including labor being
short how has or will your business
change and so these are in order of the
response again we regrouped their
open-ended responses and in order of
priority this is what they said orchard
design planting systems and
equipment to be more labor efficient was
the biggest thing that they were doing
the other thing that goes the second
item that goes along with this is
downsizing producing less and decreasing
late acreage and and what that really
means is with these high density
planting systems that we have converted
to in this state over the last ten years
with a vengeance we are producing more
apples on less acreage or more apples
far more apples on the same acreage in
some cases the other the third thing
that they said is we are relying more on
h-2a than we have in the past which
means two things so sometimes the grower
was not in the h-2a program was but was
going to go to the h-2a program to hire
workers and others were hiring more
workers through the h-2a program and
then forth and this is not surprising
either it's going on for decades if if a
business becomes too labor-intensive or
too complex there are certain people who
say we just cannot come up with the
capital or we don't want to proceed with
this business it is the business is not
viable for the next generation and we're
going to opt out so some further
comments on the open-ended questions
growers are reporting a shift to
high-density planning systems higher
yields per acre platforms and other
equipment dramatically improve labor
efficiency I took this photo at the
fruits at the fruit extension fruit tore
up in orleans county this summer and
this gives you a look at two things one
is the planning system is the tall
spindle planning system a high density
system that has been developed and
refined and promoted at geneva and the
other thing is there you have in the
middle of that row a platform and that
platform the workers stand on the
platform and can prune and can pick and
do other operations that make the
operations far more labour efficient
than they ever were before and so the
one thing that is really interesting to
me about all of this is that the
high-density planting system and labor
efficiency were not developed
independently it was all developed
together to be integrated so so all of
these the row spacings and the tying and
all of these things were all put
together in a way that labor could be
the very most productive sogar response
to labor challenges make each full-time
equivalent worker as productive as
possible in these new systems certainly
do that eliminate excess labor and less
productive acreage I was I was in the
orchard I was up in western New York
during apple harvest and one of the
things that's increasingly clear land
prices in western New York and around
the state are going up dramatically and
so if you can be more productive on the
same acreage or less acreage then you
don't have the extra capital investment
of new acreage and new high-priced
acreage reduce risk by using the h-2a
program and I haven't said anything
about this yet but in New York
immigration enforcement pressure has
been dramatic and
the most likely reason appears to be our
border with Canada and a high critical
mass of enforcement officers in Ison and
Border Patrol out of Buffalo and in the
North Country and so one there are
several reasons why a grower would use
the h-2a program one is to make sure
that they have the workers they need if
there is a little bit of labor shortage
out there the other is to make sure that
they don't have workers that are
undocumented and could get deported in
the middle or detained in the middle of
the harvest season or the middle of the
growing season so reducing risk is
becoming a more important part of the
h-2a program and a motivation especially
in this state where we have so much
enforcement pressure up I go to other
states I talked to folks from other
states and New York and Vermont seem to
have a disproportionate share of
enforcement pressure and the growers
feel that as they try to operate their
businesses and then the other thing that
in there open-ended questions that the
growers said is we're going to continue
to aggressively advocate for immigration
reform I already made this point growers
reported increasing reliance on h-2a
because other workers are not available
they can manage risk and it's a response
to enforcement enforcement pressure now
the h-2a paradox and I've sort of been
leading up to this growers who use the
h-2a program are often very critical of
the program it's expensive there's a lot
of paperwork occasionally you don't get
your workers on time and growers don't
like that they want they're in the
program so that their labor needs will
be predictable and they're the labor
force will be predictable
and so there can be a few problems along
the way that said some growers ever
reported in their open any question on
this survey that without the h-2a
program they don't know what they do
without the h-2a program they would
probably be out of business and so so
h-2a is especially in this state is
becoming more important so now that I've
sort of now that I've gone through some
of the things we found and there are a
lot more there's a lot more information
that will be in our publication that
will be posted on the Dyson website in
the extension section so now that we've
gotten to this point I want to put this
into context a little bit of immigration
reform and what does what do some of
these things mean to immigration reform
when we talk about what agriculture
wants out of immigration reform policy
what agriculture wants is very clear and
the entity that speaks for agriculture
in Washington is called the agricultural
workforce coalition and it is a it is a
coalition of dozens of agricultural
groups like American Farm Bureau Western
Western growers western United daring
men and so on all of the major farm
organizations that deal with labor
intensive agriculture are part of this
coalition and the coalition speaks with
one voice and it says the following and
right before the last Congress about
almost three years ago after the
presidential election they got together
and redid this and reinforce their
position which is that agricultural
operations must have
access to a stable and skilled workforce
and we need to do this by doing two
things one is providing an adjustment in
immigration status for the undocumented
workers that are already working in
agriculture so that came they can stay
and work in agriculture and the other
thing that is needed is to address
workforce needs with a modern guest
worker visa program and what that means
is if we continue with the h-2a program
it needs to be fixed and if we don't we
need a new program that improves the
good things that that improves upon the
good things that we already have in the
h-2a program and one of the realities of
policy in this country is that
government policy is often based on
inertia and the likelihood that we are
going to throw out the completely throw
out the h-2a program and start over is
pretty slim in my estimation which means
immigration reform needs to look at what
what's going right with the h-2a program
think about what needs to be improved
and then come up with a new guest worker
program that will combine those two
things so that's what our culture says
it wants so let's we just started the
114th Congress a few weeks ago let's
look at what happened in the 113th
Congress the last Congress that ended on
July thirty-first the Senate in that
Congress passed s.744 which was a
comprehensive immigration reform bill it
had its own separate agricultural title
largely because that's what the
agricultural workforce coalition wanted
and in my opinion we prob alegra culture
could probably have not done
much better there was an opportunity for
legalized status for the undocumented
workers and there was a new and improved
guest worker program that would make
some real changes to the h-2a program so
what happened if when it then became the
House of Representatives term turn to do
something with this piece of legislation
last year at this time we knew that the
window there was a window before the
midterm elections right up until about
the August recess they there were some
bills introduced none of them that were
one was introduced by the Democrats and
it looked just like s.744 and that was
going nowhere the other bills introduced
by the Republicans failed to do anything
about the 11 million illegal immigrants
in this country and at the end of the
day the August recess came nothing was
done no bills were passed out of the
house and and at that point President
Obama began threatening and saying well
if you're not going to do if you the
house if the Congress isn't going to do
anything that I'm going to do something
on my own which he did it probably it
only it probably only would affect what
he did with his executive action a small
number of workers to make them allow
them deferred status and deferred
detention and deportation so I don't see
it as having a big impact on agriculture
and all the organizations that represent
agriculture within 24 hours of the
executive action being announced came
out and said this is no substitute the
executive action is no substitute for
comprehensive immigration reform which
we still want and are going to work hard
to get
so that brings us to the new Congress
the 114th Congress I had the opportunity
to be with a group of farmers who were
visiting House members on Capitol Hill
two weeks ago and it is increasingly
apparent that to me that the House of
Representatives cannot agree on how what
to do with the 11 million illegal
immigrants what immigration reform
should look like and the likely it seems
unlikely that anything is going to
happen in the hundred and fourteen
Congress because we have the
presidential elections that will be in
full swing by this summer and when we
have an election cycle it's very hard to
get these kinds of tough pieces of
legislation passed so it is it seems
unlikely to me that we're going to have
much progress or any progress in this
Congress which means we're probably
going to have to wait until we get a new
president and another new Congress and
hope at that time that we can get some
movement so what if you are an apple
grower if you're a farm manager how do
you think about all of this stuff that
comes out of the survey and emanates
from the immigration reform process I I
think growers there's no doubt that
growers will continue to improve labor
efficiency these new systems have worked
great and they continue to take out the
older varieties and the tall trees and
put in these new dwarf trees and these
new high density systems that is going
to continue they have said in their open
ended question answers that they're
going to stay involved in the
immigration reform legislative process
and I think that if I think we have an
environment now that if the
organizations like Farm Bureau and
others send out a letter
that says it is time to call your
Congressman this this issue is so
important that if there is a piece of
legislation to support or to oppose
those offices will be flooded because
farmers are now paying a lot of
attention to this and then finally
develop a human resource strategic plan
to include improved wages and benefits
improved housing and supervisory
training one of the things that comes
out of this discussion of immigration
reform is how do we keep the
undocumented workers once they have a
piece of paper that says that they have
a legalized status and I think that one
of the answers to that is going to be
these three points the wages benefits
housing and supervisory training now
with housing apple growers have a leg up
over for example dairy farmers and we're
a big we're a big dairy state well apple
growers because of seasonal label labor
already have housing inspections dairy
farmers don't and if so dairy farmers
are going to have we still have to be
vigilant in the fruit industry but dairy
farmers are going to have to have a
whole new way of thinking about their
housing and some of the regulations that
may come about because they are less
regulated than the growers are at this
point at this point I will stop there
and I think we've got we stop it at 110
so we've got time for some questions and
comments and rebuttals and so on
for me
can't work on songs
but we did was a lot of things that are
being done today show me your slugs if
the apples a lot of different things
that work I know farming has change in
what I was changed we still do
engineering 1l to have some of our
students working summers
process not to my knowledge but I might
not be the best person to answer that
question allora there are a lot of
internships available to students and so
those opportunities exist in form of
internships okay yeah both are off
campus here I I know like the fruit
group right here or not has five every
summer they come and take them on a work
on various aspects of growing fruit
plantations as engravings them yeah so I
think there are there's also a form of
course you can take on farm equipment
and use you sign up for like a regular
course and every week you know a couple
of days with you out and you learn how
to drive tractors and hook up equipment
right you guys chin down positions for
people it would a post and clipping for
the you mentioned the honeycrisp apples
right what is the new york state what is
the economic people i mean you know i
don't many christmas with relatively new
and also very high-value variety what is
the like what proportion of farms are
growing like these high-value varieties
that would actually require that versus
something for rent delicious or a granny
smith right we did not we did not have
enough information from the survey to
answer that question and I don't know
the answer to that question that those
the newer varieties keep expanding and
the old varieties game keep being
replaced so farmers as a whole in
general tend to be conservative
politically and folks that are sort of
pushing for you know slowing down you
know no katha citizenship and no amnesty
now latter also political conservative
so there seems to be there must be some
tension between those two groups is an
eight puts the nature that conversation
between the politically conservative
politicians and politically conservative
farmer is it different than what we hear
it sort of a general public and what's
the farmers say to the politician who
seems to be working against their
interests and this was a good thing
about that and that's there is a
fascinating question I can tell you what
happened two weeks ago and we were on
Kevin we so I went with a group of
growers and we went to five or six House
members office and usually end up talk
talking to the staff now some of those
congressmen are new and so then you have
to start at the beginning and say why
all this stuff is important but some of
them by tom green and others have been
around for a long time chris collins and
they've heard this from the same growers
for several years running and so then
you don't have to educate them and so
then it's likely that one of the growers
will say well so what he tells really
what you think is going on and one of
the things we've heard was this is one
of the visit folk from one of the staff
members was there are two dozen
knuckleheads in Congress and the house
that do not want anything want to do
anything with the 11 million
undocumented immigrants and so you have
that small group that is very bold goal
and very dug in and trying to find the
middle
Republican system is very very difficult
does that help to answer the question i
mean the if you're Tom Reed or chris
collins and you come from an upstate
agricultural district you get and you
know that the farmers are not going to
get off your back so they're going to
these conservatives and trying to get
something going and the Conservatives
are having and ours are just stained up
yet smart to Marvins question the
argument isn't ideological it's between
those in agriculture who want them to do
something and the Republicans who can't
do anything well I'd end up explaining
why it can't be done and we we have to
remember politically that those House
members who are taking that that he ends
off we don't want to do anything on
immigration approach or anything for the
illegal immigrants they come from
districts whose electric want the same
thing so while Chris Collins's
electorate wants this moving for
agriculture you've got another person
conservative Republican and conservative
Republican district who doesn't who
wants the same thing that that house
member is safe Geneva do you have any
questions as wondering on that point we
you have down there on that last slide
whether they're looking to current
employers like McDonald's that trains a
lot of people in supervisory training is
a source of labor or
along those lines we not sure I
completely understand the question are
would we get would we stand to hire some
workers away from mcdonalds is that what
you're saying right so it's not
immigrant labor they're working it sort
of similar wages and they have some
train I think that that word there is a
difference between outdoor work and
working in the elements and so on and
working at McDonald's number one number
two it gets back to this whole question
of will Americans do these jobs and I
have a feeling that there are probably
some mcdonalds managers who wonder the
same thing if Americans with do those
jobs so that these well labor levels I
think we're going to continue to
struggle with how to get the workers and
get them trained and compensate them to
get the work done I actually don't see
much movement between a child like
McDonald's and an apple orchard but I do
see both employers out of the same
challenges marked just one thing I we
always take it for granted that h-2a is
an oppressive program and you've
explained the fact that it's difficult
for employers why is it that way why
isn't it built to to provide that stage
will work
what he wants and I think a large part
of the reason is that when laws like
this are enacted the labor advocates
have had something to say about them and
so there are assurances put into the
program I think part of the paperwork is
part of that I think the wages apartment
that the waiver erotic pics has said the
workers need more than what you're
willing to give it so they compromise on
something that does have higher wages
and more restrictions Obama way
okay I think we're done this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu